this is the warriors they're
the best franchise in how many decades
really
winning like they're winning right now
is unprecedented the way they're playing
kevin for you we want you back at any
contract you would like
why was that even a discussion well you
were talking about that
yeah for sure we want to do this thing
again
kd is willing to take less it is
reported that he's going to take a
little bit less
you know he'll be a free agent again
next summer if he goes short term
where do the warriors go long term i
just come in here and go to work and try
to get better as a player every day and
help my teammates as much as
possible i just thought it was one of
those plays where i could show a little
bit more emotion than i usually show
those talking heads who say we're better
without them that's just ludicrous like
that's crazy
this is the best player in the world you
could put him on the 30th best team
league and that's that team will make
the playoffs that's how talented he is
just trying to see how i can be perfect
every time down i know that's impossible
but if i strive towards it then you know
i give myself a goal to reach
so i'm just trying to keep getting
better every single night
go to five finals in a row and this team
right now
is exhausted kevin was getting on
draymond for not passing the ball and
draymond took exception
sometimes it can get a bit overwhelming
it's gonna get worse before it gets
better
something going wrong with this team i
deal with it
there's some cracks right now with the
warriors and i'd be concerned if i was
the organization
these championships are supposed to be
hard to rack up
he disrespected kd their relationship
won't be the same hey kevin have you and
draymond been able to hash anything out
no i'm never going to change who i am
he went on to disparage the man both in
the huddle and the locker room
so much so that the general manager and
front office's warriors decide to spend
dream i agree
can you break through that mental
fatigue for a 3p and now you talk about
a team that's been there five times
it's about mental fatigue y'all come
here every day
ask me about free agency asks my
teammates my coaches you rile up the
fans about it
let us play basketball
he just has to take his time and put
those pass games behind him and move
forward
like i said we know the formula to
success for us as a group
but you know trying to get up every
night to be dominant that's a tough
thing mentally
once we dive deep into basketball then
the the rumors and
everything that swirls around the team
really don't mean too much
you just don't want to play around with
the clippers they have some guys that
can go off and beverly
getting into durant's face for ant once
again just smiling back
this time durant a foul fall and duran
who barks out of durant
they're both out they've both been just
thrown out of the game
double technicals
you know i want to have a little back
and forth with patrick beverly i'm kevin
durant
you know who i am y'all know who i am
come on man don't poke the bear you want
the wolf if you want the wolf
you get everything that comes along with
it right
yeah i'm kevin durant i know who i am he
said yesterday he's kevin durant
and showed everybody who kevin durant is
you talking about locked in
when they come out and play like this
nobody can beat them there's nobody that
can keep this guy from getting shots
i think you'll see the warriors at their
best i think they know what's at stake
i mean he's kevin durant i promise we
try
sometimes you come across special people
and it doesn't matter
what you send to him and he showed it
tonight he put them guys on his
shoulders
he was like i'm kevin durant y'all know
who i am that's a bold statement to make
when you're about to go
see some guys that's extremely
competitive that was one of the great
performances i've ever
seen in my life you know he's the
ultimate weapon because there's no
defense for kevin
durant
i come in and go to work every day i
don't cause no problems
holding on to his right achilles
wow i don't think he knows what he did
he thought
someone hit him in the achilles
i don't know the extent of his injury
but that's never fun man
he's one of the best to ever do it i
want to try to win this for him
we miss him i'm going to miss him man
it's not the same being out there
without them you know i don't really
know too much about this injury i'm just
leaning into the hands of the
team doctors and i trust the direction
that they kind of put me in
no kevin durant is not playing but yes
his presence is constantly being felt
how about one of the best to ever play
the game kevin durant
walking you out to the floor and we're
down
for the last two for the nba title the
raptors
get the victory here in game
the one raptors are going to be one win
away from an nba title
you've got one last hope and that hope
is kevin durant
and this was the day he targeted his
team has put him in position
to make history not only will he start
but according to steve kerr
kevin durant will not have any minutes
restrictions whatsoever
hurry to durant here's his first shot
and looks pretty good there
rattles home a three durant tries
another three
two for two is kevin durant durant for
three kevin durant his third
three-pointer already
vodka trying to stay with durant knocks
it away and duran slipping
miranda goes down holding his leg and
durant grabbing that right leg
his teammates going over to check on him
the expectation is that this will be a
torn achilles tendon
there's a new nba champion and it's a
team from toronto canada
we the north are now we the champions
the raptors
the 2019 nba champs
for him to put his health on the line to
come back and compete at the highest
level
he's one of the best to ever do it
the feeling the last couple months
before the injury was
kevin's probably going to leave then he
comes back and he gets injured and you
go
what it changes the whole dynamic
well i know how good i am and i know the
demand on my skills in the league
east is a little wide open every day is
a challenge to stay at this level
historic night for the nets franchise
kevin durant is reportedly headed to the
brooklyn nets
and so now it's just like they put the
cherry on top
to absolutely maximize their team this
is a great job
so i never looked at me switching teams
as a new challenge every day i wake up i
gotta
fight against that standard i set for
myself still going to be
kevin durant's team yeah i deserve to
live in a good city
i've been in the league for 12 years and
i get to make a decision like this
of course i only looked at cities like
that oh this team is going to be much
better
i like this move all around and this is
really the culmination
of just a master class in building a
franchise by sean marks
kevin durant is back on the floor and
doing what people want to see him do
which is play basketball
i felt like it was a time for her change
and i wanted to play for a new team
former beloved kevin durant steps out of
the golden state court for the first
time
since his defection in games like that
you're going to be emotional
i didn't really think about what i was
leaving behind or like
would be accomplished i put that up on
the shelf already
kd returns you go to play you go to win